we can't really do a whole review of
this movie because it would just sound
like we're reviewing the other two we
did it
we watched Fifty Shades freed yes let's
break this down and reason to see and
reasons not to see this movie people
let's hop right into a no beating around
the back
the CGI book as per the first film
remember that saga no reason to see
number one Dakota Johnson is
occasionally ain't good I think the
biggest surprise of this film while
there are definite scenes when Dakota
Johnson is pretty flat there's an
occasional moment or two it's really
under a minute where I would look over
to my girlfriend be like oh yeah really
emotional here and I believe this I
guess I would say that there are only a
handful of moments in which she truly
shines out however I will say that for
me anyway is she is the most watchable
thing about this movie especially but
kind of the past three there's something
about her weird quirky portrayal with
this character that just works for me I
don't know why no I thought that in
terms of what she had actual scenes to
do in this movie it's like the
conversational parts where she's just
having a conversation I don't believe
her but when she has like an emotional
thing to do I really buy her she has a
really good confrontation moment yeah
yeah took me completely by surprise and
it's like the one moment that randomly
crests into actual relationship drama
the likes of which you wish for so much
I guess what works for me about her is
is that when it's not particularly good
she seems to have just the right pitch
she seems to get what she's doing sure I
think reason to see number two some of
the sex well yeah some of it's alright
some of it's whatever there are certain
scenes where you're like now it's kind
of hot let's move on the reasons not se
reasons not to see number one bad
performances alright so I didn't take
the time to go on IMDB and respect this
[ __ ] have all these actors but looking
up all their names and stuff but I can
tell you Jamie Dornan does not get
any better is just as flat as ever in
fact he seems like he cares even less
this time around fifty shades gray he
sucked fifty shades darker
he tried fifty Shades freed there's no
point that's kind of the progression the
first two you got number three and
there's like other characters in here
who are just not as good as Jamie Dornan
a lot of it yeah sure falls on the
writing of them but it just really seems
like the only one who really cared to
show up was occasionally Dakota Johnson
probably because she felt like she was
going out with a bang ah cuz of the sex
of which there is a little bit in this
movie reason not to see number two the
lack of sex I can't tell you how many
scenes there were in this movie I could
at least make a three but so much of
this movie when it starts getting hot
it cuts or whether you think that are
about to do it they don't yeah a lot of
the dramatic tension one way or the
other always kind of involves them
wanting to and attempting sex and then
either a relationship dispute or some
kind of weird outside force getting in
the way yeah so this is a big tease of a
movie it really is just teasing I mean
when the sex is there it's okay it was
weird because the first Fifty Shades
movie I watched it and you could make
this argument for the other ones but
specifically this one whenever there was
a sex scene I was like there's really no
point for this scene at all at least the
first two are like about this is why
they're so drawn to each other or
whatever I don't know we've already
married him and they're having sex I'm
like this does nothing for the movie so
I don't even feel like this is hot I'm
just so aware of your spin on their
passions actors having sex guys passion
no different they don't do any
experiments the most not used to seeing
a lot of sex you know probably the most
disappointing part was the marketing of
this says don't miss the climax and then
there's a sex scene coming up where I'm
like this must be the thing there's
peanuts this and then it cuts to black
movies weird in that department too I'd
be like they've missed a big opportunity
to really embrace sex instead of yeah
just kind of showing you a random scene
once in a while that shows just a little
bit more than you're used to seeing I'll
admit the first one I didn't care for
the sex in there this one I really don't
give a [ __ ] about at least in fifty
shades darker there were sex scenes and
their chemistry where I was like pretty
hot actually what they were not a couple
of these sex scenes were we're too
deleting and whatnot as parts of a
coherent movie not so much no I just
laughed reason not to see number three
the writing and directing the whole
movie this film I feel like was like a
music video based on just a stack of
different catalogs because so much of
this movie just them going to different
other nice real people places and
wearing different other nice outfit it's
exactly the same we can't really do a
full review of this movie because it
would just sound like we're reviewing
the other cue to go out and live their
life and whatever and then getting
interrupted by like the occasional
murder attempt and then just yeah ramaa
between I mean that's one thing I'll
kind of give this movie credit for is
that the first two had like these random
parts are like they're trying to be a
thriller about it and I'll admit in the
finale of this film
it got randomly intense I wasn't like
gripped by it but I wasn't pulled in
enough to be like this is pretty intense
[ __ ] actually right here I didn't love
that storyline but I will say it was
more effective than it added and it
added some intensity to it
it allowed Anastasia to become a stunt
driver out of nowhere yeah they have
like three plots in this movie they got
married Anastasia wants to have a kid
and her job she else there's like a
subplot where she's like really trying
to be professional working and stuff
there's this other plot about the guy
from fifty shades darker who's like
stalking Anastasia or is he stalking
Christian now which one is this goes
back to the beginning in this movie or
beginning of this yeah so in the movies
unfolding the stalker plot becomes a
little more intriguing that's the part
that had some intensity to it the other
plot lines are so dull this is all the
same exact [ __ ] that the first two did
where it keeps seeming like it's gonna
go somewhere but it doesn't that's like
the whole thing at least in the finale
it kind of wraps up the plot lines where
I feel like the first to kind of just
end
like what the hell is them hanging out
in this movie especially the first hour
and 20 minutes of this our 40-minute
movie is that I'm just kicking it for
most of it there are a couple distinct
arcs about this movie but nothing really
that gives you a catharsis or an impact
or that yeah it really feels like it
built to something like it technically
did they get over a couple issues and
avoid being killed you know what this
movie does what the other ones do is
they set up conflicts Christian disrupts
Anastasia at work because she won't
change her email to Anastasia gray and
it seems like you're gonna go back to
who it was gonna have problems issues
and then there's this real estate lady
who's all over Christian and then might
being a Christian brother trailer about
like you call me mrs. gray yeah and
they're really setting that up to be
something that's a that's a lot of this
movie is conflicts are introduced but
they don't get resolved or acknowledged
ever again and don't ultimately play
into the rest of the film and I get the
way that life works like that but it's
just not satisfying here they set up a
couple different storylines where you're
like whoa is this kind of significant
character like yeah something and then
they just never ever bring it back just
drop it just rush right past stuff
there's there's suffer all those like
joking the theater going oh [ __ ] and
then nothing
they just don't bother to acknowledge
stuff they just drop so much in here and
the things that they kept the focus on
with a stalker story and the pregnancy
kind of become interesting and that's
mainly because of Dakota Johnson a
performance yeah and they would have
been more interesting in a better
written movie that actually had to use
them for anything more than just basic
plot conflicts you know so yeah I mean
the sex ain't exciting in this film the
plot itself is more dull than it's ever
been
ah that's better than 50 shades of grey
depends on your threshold yeah it was
weird because I stuck with these shades
darker I was like you know what I
enjoyed it I thought it was fun I
thought they knew what they were doing
this one went right back to Fifty Shades
of Grey for me at least 50 shades of
grey had enticing sex scenes to some
degree here you're like they're not they
don't even care about the sex anymore
you could do anything kinky or new it is
they do see up there I'm like well makes
it extinct II is the fact that they have
actors doing this in a big movie but
when you think about the actual sex acts
they're doing
it's not special oh my god it's kind of
crazy that we see like simulated
fellatio on screen for a prolonged time
but at the same time you're like yes
it's really not that but I mean what am
I heard most people doing that on
machine there's a whole panoramic rabbit
hole to go down with the Biddy is one
thing you had to do with this movie
everything else fails does make the sex
really cool an entire job is to be taboo
but that's the problem is you can't
appeal to everybody and you can't keep
everybody if you get too taboo you can
cut back on sex they try to handsome
plot and character stuff not really what
they truly could tell their trial I can
ship fast in the Furies it's like that's
the level everything's on but it's just
them trying to have a honeymoon and get
through some issues ultimately in the
end I really walked away feeling like
this movie had the potential this
franchise had the potential to be a
psychological study of an abusive
dominant and a codependent victim in
Asia and also it could have been a story
with the theme of lust versus love and
like just because you're insanely
attracted and loved sex does that really
mean you love it's none of that it's
it's really super dull there's a lot of
rias one hat had soul you know the first
one seemed like they it was more aware
of what this was there are definitely
times I laughed unintentionally and a
couple times were an intentional joke
work - mm-hmm so there's that ultimately
if I were to write this movie I'd say
it's a flaccid experience ha ha Oh
whiskey dick all right reject nation did
you feel satisfied after this climax
yeah how are you dealing with the
afterglow
do you regret paying to watch this on
IMAX we describe click that notification
bell follow us on the Stardust app and
check out our patreon become a patron
today a lot of exclusive perks over
there and videos and if you did watch it
on IMAX just please give us a very
detailed description of what that was
like
sorriest thing about the movie Oh